hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk
taping garyvaynerchuk.com
and we're about to tape at npr as you
can see
don't you love their logo look at scotty
simon
you look good you look good on camera
why are you doing radio you've got it
you've got a tv
face um it's on the wrong end though
so uh had a great day here today for the
last hour and a half we did a little
kind of consulting talking about social
media
and just fascinating now we're about to
tape uh you'll be able to hear us this
sunday right on saturday um
on the eight trillion stations they have
and the one thing i came from here that
i wanted to really tell you guys about
is
i find it even with the coolest brands
in the world like npr
a lot of companies have to go through
the same old thing and you get into what
i call the half
pregnant zone and that's what i want to
talk about do not get caught
half pregnant if you want to embrace the
tools that are out there today
you've got to just go do it there should
be no excuses you probably work in a
company that has a lot of rules lawyers
the bigger the company the more red tape
slow moving but you've just got to
absolutely fight through
and whatever you can do to get into the
space and interact with your community
that's what you need to do scotty you
agree yes absolutely did you like the uh
the sit down what you did today was i
amazing were you amazing you were
amazing
an awful lot from it and uh and i i've
learned not to be half pregnant
i didn't i didn't i know you know i was
pregnant
before i didn't even know i was close to
getting you yeah i was trying to get the
problem
yeah exactly but uh but no i think i
think what gary said is absolutely
true i mean this is this is the new way
we'll be right so why delay
well i mean why put red tape why uh why
put anything in the way because you know
what happens right
go to the watch oh yeah that's right
because you know what happens
just a matter of time until you're dead